hi everyone is Jerry this is another
group of five puzzles all of them are
endgame positions with white to play and
it's up to you to determine the best
continuation in each case so in this
first one go ahead pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to puzzle 1 is
to start out with a 3 it's very
important not to go to squares here's
why running through this quick variation
where black is just moving back and
forth eventually we get to a situation
where white is having to either go to be
six which is stalemate or any other move
allowing King takes pawn one slight
variation assuming that a four is still
the first move played white isn't
successful by trying to sneak their King
around because after King a5 King b7
King before a six
after these pawns have been exchanged
the black King maintains a strong
position and will be able to hold a draw
so the only solution is going to be to
start out with a three and it's going to
be completely different
after all these puns have been advanced
and the white pawn arrives on b7 the
black King is on a different square at
this point now able to make use of c7
the white King can slip in and then
promote on the next turn so that's the
solution to puzzle 1 moving on to the
second once again white to play pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
of this one is to start out with either
king d4 or King c4 it's very important
not to just go right ahead trying to
promote your pawn because after King d8
c7 we have a similar situation as we
experienced in the first puzzle where if
King c6 that stalemate and any other
move allows King takes pawn which is a
drum so what's important to make use of
is triangulation and that involves
moving the king three times in a row and
starting first with either king c4 king
d4 ultimately landing this King back to
this d5 square but then have it be black
to move so we want to establish as white
here this same position but have it be
black to move so this can be
accomplished by going to d4
and if at any point that black King
makes use of c7 for example King seats
have but we can now pivot on this c5
square and then get to b6 this pond will
fall and white will be winning so
instead of king c7 right here let's just
have the King go back to d8 King c4
similarly king c7 King c5 etc so the
black King essentially going back and
forth finally we have this same position
rising but now it's black to move and
that's going to be much much different
because King da King d6 King c8 Kings
excuse me c7 King b7 and now sneaking
our king up and promotion next one thing
to just be a bit conscious of you don't
want to promote to a queen here that's
stalemate so just being a bit cautious
of that you could also you could just
promote to a rook or play your king to
this c6 square King 8 promote to a queen
now with check and then mate so that's
the solution to puzzle to moving out to
the 3rd once again white to play pause
the video see if we can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is Bishop to e6 it's very
important to take into account the
following we're working with the rook
pawn and a bishop that cannot control
the corner square so what that means is
that if the black King can get to that
corner square it's going to be a draw so
the goal on the white end here is going
to prevent the black King from getting
there Bishop e6 is a step in this
direction knowing now that King f8 could
be met with h6 which is guarding the g7
square and with this square also being
guarded and this one the black King is
going to have to go in the other
direction and white would be able to
Queen however there is more resistance
that can be put up and it comes in the
following form came to e7
y could ignore the threat on the bishop
and just push the pawn taking is going
to result in promotion in just two moves
after king to f6 another key move Bishop
to f5 it's very important to see these
key moves right here first Bishop e6
then Bishop to f5 preventing the King
from making use of g6 and after
came to f7 the other key move Bishop to
h7 preventing the King from making use
of g8 all three of these squares being
guarded King f6 now we have this wall of
four squares right here being guarded
the black King cannot get to that corner
square white is now making good progress
and eventually the White King maintains
a strong position the bishop can move
and then finally the pawn can promote so
that's a solution to puzzle three moving
on to the fourth once again white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best continuation for white ok the
solution here is to play King to see a
moving the pawn is going to result in a
loss after king c6 King c8 King b6 King
ba trying to get this pawn up like that
we just have King takes pawn and this
White King is not going to be fast
enough to catch the pun so what is the
solution well after King to c8 King c6
King to b8 King to be 5 because
otherwise you know moving this pawn
right now we're just gonna have the pawn
pushing three times it'll be white
that'd be winning so King b5 and here's
the key move right here King to b7
looking to just advance this pawn and so
King takes pawn and now White has been
successful by shifting that King down
like this because they're in a position
to finally just in the nick of time
catch this pond before it's able to
clean successfully so that's a solution
to puzzle for moving on to the last once
again white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to this one is
to start out with Bishop to d2 it's
important to recognize that white cannot
prevent both of these pods from queening
and the attempt to try and advance this
pawn in order to establish some past
pond may be involving this b6
pond is not going to be successful and
so what white is needing to do is
something very very clever and
what that involves is a self stalemate
starting with Bishop - D - G - Bishop to
a5 g1 equaling a queen and after b4
regardless of blacks next move the
result is going to be a stalemate and by
the way it does not matter which pawn
advances to become a queen the best that
could maybe be done I guess is just to
capture this pawn but again we have an
instance here of stalemate one of those
self stalemate it's a very rare position
to see so that's all for this video as
always I hope you're able to take
something away from it take care bye